في تطور لافت نقلت شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه عن مصدر عسكري اوكراني قوله ان
القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه هي على الارجح
من تقف وراء هجمات غامضه بطائرات مسيره ضد
قوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هذا
الشهر
k
تستخدم الان من قبل جميع التشكيلات
العسكريه سواء كانت الاستخبارات او القوات
الارضيه لدينا القليل من المسيرات مثل
البير قطار وليكا ومختلف المسيرات الاخرى
تستخدم من كل التشكيلات
العسكريه
you are watching a thermal imaging
video depicting military forces equipped
in hightech gear far more sophisticated
than the sudanes have demonstrated
[موسيقى]
today
المخابرات الاوكرانيه هي الوحيده التي
تراقب قواه فاجنر بل الكثير من المخابرات
في العالم ونعلم جيدا ما الذي تقوم به
فاجنر وفاغنر